what
who's is that yours no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no can i
sit in it no
[Music]
i'm here with justin bieber today and
today we're going to see what do people
think about justin bieber oh my god love
him but yummy is just like not it it's
not that good
[Laughter]
my hand shaking take it quick
to say our first guest is a social media
sensation
well that really just doesn't cut it um
i'm actually
really excited about this interview and
i
take it seriously because david dobrik
is someone
who i feel is a very unique and
important person in this world
he is someone who has a very loud voice
and a very big platform and
i'm really excited to talk to him
because
what he does in this world is
meaningful and as someone who
loves joy and silliness
and all of those things the other side
of me
is someone who really cares about
taking care of people and um
showing the possibilities in the world
and so when i think of david david
dobrik i
get really excited because it isn't talk
it's all really happening in his world
and we're all watching it
so without further ado ladies and
gentlemen
david dobrik hi hi
how are you that was brutally nice
oh that was that was it seems like we
paid you off to say all that that was
like a paragraph usually i get here's
youtuber david dobrik but that was
awesome thank you
no no no you are anything but just a
youtuber
you are someone who uh
first of all your numbers i mean 8
billion
views and you know 20 million followers
is obviously so impressive you know
i think back to like candid camera and i
think about the history of the medium of
how you reach people while being
authentically who you are
was there always a time where you
thought you wanted to have this be
this sort of like feel-good
philanthropic
like surprise people pay mortgages
like donate cars when did you
sort of think like oprah and jackass
would bake a really potent combination
with a dash of products that's funny
when did i first i don't know i was a
big fan growing up i was a big fan of
military surprise videos
like i loved when soldiers would come
home from like these long tours
and they'd surprise their families and i
was like i'm such a sucker for reactions
like
whether someone's reacting like they're
terrified or they're scared
um or they're super happy like i love it
all
um so when i got the chance to surprise
people in a positive way rather than
like scare them with
like a spider or some kind of an animal
that's what like i wanted to lean
towards
it's the most selfish feeling to
surprise others with people because like
the joy you get from them being happy
is just like it it pays it back tenfold
like it's the best
and and i think some people
unfortunately have a little bit
of a gotcha i'm not a big fan of that
and when i watch your stuff there is
such a goodness
there there is thanks there is this
sweetness this kindness this joy where
you do really get off at watching
people's reactions but it's based in
good
i always say that like the moments that
you've seen my videos are very much
the real moments that i'm experiencing
in real life too and that's why i like
making
um videos on youtube is because it's
it's such an
intimate thing and you can have such an
intimate interaction with strangers and
you can have like that actual moment
like when you're like
there was a time we surprised this daca
girl i think it was with like twenty
five thousand dollars i'm not sure
but like it was just me and her and her
friends sitting in
in like in her jeep and like it feels
all so
real and like being able to capture that
moment and having that forever
is like the the best and you are daca
you are a dreamer
right so yeah is there is that
personal in that moment yeah that was
that was it was it was really funny
because i i was in texas and this kid
walks up to me and he goes my
girlfriend's daca just like you i am too
um she works two jobs she has a kid
she's 19 years old
and and then we went to go meet up with
her and her two other friends were there
and they were also all daca
so it was like four or five of us
sitting in this car and it was like so
cool because it was just a car full of
these illegals including me and we're
just like laughing and like
and like you know making light of our
situation and that was like the coolest
thing
like to be able to um share a moment
with people like that was like really
really awesome
something that i really appreciated uh
and
and you just seemed so genuine to me and
not ego driven
and so much more joy driven but when you
stopped doing your videos was there sort
of a
i need to just stop moment i i don't
know what what was it for you
i think there's i think there's also
this thing with with
specifically people in social media is
it it moves so quickly
and you're your own boss so you're
pumping out content like as fast as you
can
and i think it's really easy to get like
so
like infatuated with like the instant
gratification of it and like
and like how quickly you can you can
make stuff and you just get like
addicted to like
making videos and and making content
and i remember when i stopped it was
like very much like i was like entering
civilization again it was
i don't know how to explain it sounds so
bizarre but it was like i wasn't
there and i was like never present for
like the last three four years i was
just like in this like
in this zone of go go go and i know it
sounds ridiculous and i know people at
home he makes youtube videos why is that
but um but that's what that's what it
felt like that's the thing you
don't just make youtube videos and i
appreciate that i think
that i i think you have a big civil
responsibility on your hands
because so many people are watching you
and when you take a pause
i think you are saying is it is okay for
all of us
to take off the helmet ah thanks
and stop for a minute it's really
important just to hit refresh on the
whole thing and just take a moment and
be like okay
this is what i was doing this is what i
need to change and like you know let me
get back to being a human for a little
bit
you're very enthusiastic and like
charming
and excitable and all of those things
and believe me i've been thinking about
this lately
because i have my dark moments do you
have dark moments because you're so
excitable out there like
when the cameras are off i am a little
dark and like i am hard on myself and
i'm not miss mary's sunshine like when
the cameras go off do you
are you are you intense about your work
like do you have a different personality
that comes up a little bit
i'm so i'm so so hard on myself um
yeah but yeah i think i think that i
think that comes with anybody or any
anybody that wants
you know that is an entertainer i think
there are definitely dark moments but
those aren't the moments that you want
other people to see for
you know a number of reasons but but
that doesn't take away
the the authenticity of the real moments
that you're actually drawing like it's
not like you know it's not like we come
on here and we like put on this like
fake front where we're like we're happy
but really behind closed doors we're
we're miserable i still think that
i'm you know for the most part a super
super happy person but there are
definitely moments where i'm like ah
nothing's going my way right now so
we're both crazy
but we're both really happy and we both
really care about what we do
and i like that you're hitting so many
cylinders you have a perfume
yeah i i have a perfume i honestly if
i'm being completely honest why i did
the perfume other than the fact that i
like
really really love it i've just been
such a big fan of perfume commercials
and
commercials in general and quite
specifically there's a natalie portman
dior commercial
of course i'm like obsessed with yeah i
love natalie portman to death
so that's like so i've always wanted to
make like a commercial of my own so i
got to make a little commercial for my
perfume which was
which i was really excited about um and
i'm just like a big fan of the scent
by the way i am so excited
for dyspo are you kidding that is going
to be huge oh thanks that means a lot so
now we're doing this dyspo thing
and it's slowly going to turn into um
sort of like a social media where you
can
kind of share share those pictures with
other people
i used to go to like some parties at my
friend's house and they would put
disposable cameras all around the house
and instead of everyone instagramming
all night and waiting to get the right
shot and being like wait wait move here
move here
they would just take quick disposable
moment uh disposable pictures
and it literally never ruined a moment
like i don't know i'm just i'm really
excited for that to make it work
you are just amazing i was so excited to
talk to you
really and truly i marvel i was so
excited to talk to you
i was i i really appreciate all those
words and
uh i don't know i'm sure you know by now
but i'm the biggest
fan of 50 first dates i love that but
your friend jason doesn't agree
right no no so i was trying to tell him
i was like
50 first states is in the top 10 best
movies of all time
and he was he just didn't understand it
and i was i'm yeah um well
actually we're gonna be right back with
a surprise for jason
right yeah yeah we have jason on zoom
and i'm gonna get him to talk uh talk a
little crap about uh 50 first dates and
then you can appear and uh
set him straight um i will see you in
two minutes
we'll be right back
[Music]
you